there really is a before and after
sephora when it comes to the makeup
industry
until about 20 years ago this is how
most americans shopped for luxury makeup
a sales representative of the brand
would stand behind the makeup counter
and help customers make a purchase that
completely changed with sephora now it's
a free-for-all people walk in stores
they test whatever they want nothing is
behind the glass
so
how did this french retailer come to
dominate the global personal care and
beauty product industry and what
business practices helped make it the
industry leader that it is today
this is the economics of sephora
today the beauty retailer employs over
36 000 people in more than 2 700 stores
in over 35 countries
those stores carry over 250 beauty
brands
at this point sephora is like kind of my
second home
the sephora that we know today has its
roots in a small perfume shop that
opened in 1969 in limoges france
at that time the perfume and cosmetics
market was dominated by a service-based
retail model in which staff typically
received commissions based on sales
instead sephora used the assisted
self-service model in which customers
are free to test products in the store
have a full station where you can just
like literally grab whatever and you can
try on the lipsticks you can try in the
eye shadows i always leave looking like
a literal different person that i arrive
sephora customers can still request help
from a sales associate who sephora calls
a beauty advisor
there's a little bit more trust with the
sales representatives in sephora store
because they're brand agnostic so they
can tell you maybe you should buy the
mascara from this brand but you should
buy the blush from a different brand
sephora also bucked convention in the
manner in which it displayed its
products
so makeup items are next to each other
whereas from the same brand a fragrance
would be in the fragrance aisle and the
same brand a skincare product will be in
the skincare aisle then in 1997 founder
dominique mondino sold sephora to the
large luxury retail conglomerate lvmh
one of the advantages of being owned by
a conglomerate like lmh is that the
company can jump very quickly on trends
and actually several of the brands that
are sold in sephora stores are owned by
lvmh one of the popular brands owned by
lvmh is fenty beauty by rihanna and then
fenty of course has a huge section the
whole row of fenty we got the lip
glosses up front sephora's success also
stems from its exclusive line of
products there's a little bit of
attention in the relationship between a
store and a brand because sephora is
such a hot store for makeup brands to
sell their products in sephora ends up
having a lot more leverage in that
relationship the sephora collection the
challenge for high-end beauty brands
these days is that they're really facing
a conundrum they've become increasingly
dependent on sephora for sales growth
but because lvmh also produces beauty
brands and there's an element of
competition there and more brands are
coming out constantly the shelf space is
shrinking five sephora products you need
to try part 10. in part due to that
product exclusivity sephora boasts a
loyal customer base here are five
sephora products you need to buy tonight
sorry i don't make the rules you just
have to so what you'll find oftentimes
on instagram or tick tock is that people
have these haul videos where they're
showing all the products that they
bought in sephora and they're going one
by one talking about them this is the
cosas tinted face oil and it's 42. i
recommend this product to everyone and
they're always like
i'm paying 42 dollars for a face oil
yes you are
many faithful customers are members of
sephora's beauty insider program which
has three different tiers and more than
25 million members
the lowest tier is the beauty insider
the next level up is vib or very
important beauty insider which users
must spend 350 in a calendar year to
unlock
the top level is called rouge which
customers can access after spending at
least a thousand dollars in a calendar
year benefits like savings increase with
each tier i'm rouge don't judge me i
know i spend a lot of money okay i get
it but the real advantage for sephora
for the beauty rewards program is that
every time a customer goes in there
sephora knows exactly what they bought
and that is very valuable information
for the company to understand
who the customer is what they're
purchasing and then down the road to be
able to market in a very personalized
way to that customer yet as much as the
company profits on exclusivity with its
products
when it comes to sephora's consumer base
the retailer takes inclusivity seriously
one of the ways that sephora has tried
to become more inclusive as by featuring
a larger number of brands in their
stores they made an effort to include
black owned brands and then also by
pushing brands to expand their product
lines and offer
products that appeal to people from
different racial groups different
ethnicities in 2021 sephora relaunched
color iq a skin tone matching technology
that the company offers to assist
customers in selecting the most natural
products for their skin tone
and sephora is still expanding in
december 2020 the company announced a
partnership with the department chain
kohl's to install 850 shops inside
kohl's stores by 2023 since opening 200
kohl's locations this summer sephora has
added 200 000 new beauty insiders in a
statement to the wall street journal a
sephora spokesperson said we want to be
an unequivocal global leader in the
prestige beauty space and a
purpose-driven brand that is a
transformative opportunity for everyone
we touch they continued by outlining
three main areas customers brands and
teams sometimes when customers step
outside the sephora store they will have
splotches of makeup all over their arms
and that really showcases what they've
been doing in the store
[Music]